What do you think of when I say the word "design"?
You probably think of things like this: finely crafted objects that you can hold in your hand,...
...or maybe logos and posters and maps that visually explain things,...
...classic icons of timeless design,...
...but I'm not here to talk about that kind of design.
I want to talk about the kind that you probably use every day and may not give much thought to,...
...designs that change all the time and that live inside your pocket.
I'm talking about the design of digital experiences and specifically the design of systems...
...that are so big that their scale can be hard to comprehend.
Consider the fact that Google processes over one billion search queries every day,...
...that every minute, over 100 hours of footage are uploaded to YouTube.
That's more in a single day than all three major US networks broadcast in the last five years combined,...
...and Facebook transmitting the photos, messages and stories of over 1.23 billion people,...
...that's almost half of the Internet population and a sixth of humanity.
These are some of the products that I've helped design over the course of my career,...
...and their scale is so massive that they've produced unprecedented design challenges,...
...but what is really hard about designing at scale is this:...
...It's hard in part because it requires a combination of two things: audacity and humility;...
...audacity to believe that the thing that you're making...
...is something that the entire world wants and needs,...
...and humility to understand that as a designer,...
...it's not about you or your portfolio; it's about the people that you're designing for,...
...and how your work just might help them live better lives.
Now, unfortunately, there's no school that offers the course Designing for Humanity 101.
I and the other designers who work on these kinds of products...
...have had to kind of invent it as we go along,...
...and we are teaching ourselves the emerging best practices of designing at scale,...
...and today, I'd like to share some of the things that we've learned over the years.
Now, the first thing that you need to know about designing at scale...
...is that the little things really matter.
Here's a really good example of how a very tiny design element can make a big impact.
Now, the team at Facebook that manages the Facebook "Like" button...
...decided that it needed to be redesigned.
The button had kind of gotten out of sync with the evolution of our brand...
...and it needed to be modernized.
Now, you might think, well, it's a tiny little button,...
...it probably is a pretty straightforward, easy design assignment, but it wasn't.
Turns out, there were all kinds of constraints for the design of this button.